in january theranose founder elizabeth
holmes was convicted on four fraud
charges in her highly publicized
criminal trial
now holmes's former top deputy and
ex-boyfriend ramesh sunny balwani is
about to go on trial for similar charges
of defrauding investors and patients
about the startup's blood testing
capabilities balwani has pleaded not
guilty he is a really important
supporting character in the tale of
theranos he was the person closest to
elizabeth holmes the star of theranos
for the entire time that she ran the
company
prosecutors say that theranos's blood
testing technology didn't work as
promised and that holmes and belwani
lied to attract more investments as the
company ran out of cash as the trial
gets underway here's an overview of
balwani's alleged role at theranos and a
look at what's to come in his criminal
fraud trial
balwani faces federal charges nearly
identical to those in elizabeth holmes's
case two counts of conspiracy to commit
wire fraud and 10 counts of wire fraud
in the end one of those charges was
dropped against elizabeth holmes due to
an error by the prosecution it was a
charge related to a patient that had
taken a theranose test although mr
balwani and his team are fighting to get
that charge dropped as well balwani
meant holmes when she was a teenager and
jointly ran theranos with her as chief
operating officer holmes and balwani
were also in a romantic relationship
that spanned more than a decade growing
and fading alongside the rise and fall
of theranos
former employees said balwani enforced a
corporate culture of secrecy and fear
until his departure in the spring of
2016.
he was not the ultimate decision maker
as she was but he was the chief
operating officer and he oversaw the lab
so he had tremendous influence and
tremendous power at theranos through
witnesses and evidence the prosecution
and defense portrayed him as a
complicated figure who both contributed
to and tried to remedy problems at
theiranos so we have a really
conflicting picture i think from miss
holmes's trial about how much mr bowwani
may have contributed to the many
problems at that lab because of his
leadership and also how much he tried to
perhaps fix some of the problems and i
think it will be really interesting to
see the extent to which that is cleared
up in mr bauwani's trial
holmes testified that balwani was in
charge of the lab operations and
financial projections shared with
investors as president and chief
operating officer
the defense argued that holmes believed
she was telling the truth about theranos
because she relied on belwani for
accurate information about the company's
operations so there was a lot of
testimony to show that the lab
had a lot of problems and a lot of those
problems seemed to be traced back to mr
bowani we also saw text messages and
emails and other pieces of evidence that
suggested that he was very passionate
about the company and really did take
efforts at times to try to remedy the
problems the prosecution also called
several witnesses who revealed how
belwani treated theranos employees
former lab worker erica chung testified
that balwani rebuffed her attempts to
raise concerns about theranos's
technology from the witnesses called by
the prosecution specifically former
employees of theranos
i think we got a consistent picture that
mr baumani
is not a nice guy he's a guy with a
short temper a short fuse he could be
really hard on employees he challenged
people such as a former lab worker erica
chung about why she was raising
questions about lab practices the
defense and prosecution also showed
hundreds of text messages that offered a
glimpse into belwani's romantic and
business relationship with holmes they
show
really the complexity of their personal
relationship and also how intertwined
their personal relationship was with
their business one and the messages also
show importantly the influence mr
balwani tried to have over how ms holmes
ran the business in many cases it's
trying to
correct things that are wrong with the
company for instance saying we need fda
clearance that 2015 text message
referred to clearance from the food and
drug administration which would declare
the company's signature nanotainers to
collect fingerprint blood an uncleared
medical device in a separate message he
said the company's lab was a disaster
zone and the prosecution was able to use
those text messages at times to show
that there were problems at this company
that elizabeth knew about that she was
informed of a pivotal moment in holmes's
testimony came when she accused belwani
of emotional and sexual abuse she
claimed balwani controlled all aspects
of her life including how much she
should eat and sleep and when she could
see family and friends a lawyer for
belwani denied the abuse allegations
at the end of the day she said in her
testimony that well she blamed him for
exerting
control over aspects of her life
elizabeth testified that mr bowani did
not have control over what she said to
investors about the company over what
she said to business partners or over
what she said to journalists
pre-trial court filings from bowani's
attorneys could also offer insight into
what's to come in his criminal trial in
one november 2021 filing balwani's
defense team sought to limit evidence
involving patients including the results
of tests that were performed using
non-theranose diagnostic equipment the
judge denied that request
in order for baowani to be found guilty
the prosecution must prove beyond a
reasonable doubt he had the intent to
defraud patients or investors about the
efficacy of theranos's blood testing
technology so in the case of investors
that mr belwani told a lie that was
significant enough that investor thought
oh well that's great i'm going to invest
in that company and that might have been
a revenue projection or a claim about
their relationship with walgreens the
pharmacy chain that wasn't true but that
was appealing enough that it caused an
investor to write them a check
[Music]